la deuxième édition de seniors où en
êtes-vous s'est déroulée ce jeudi 22
septembre au pôle emploi de saint pierre
un forum dédié aux seniors de plus de 55
ans bénéficiant du rsa depuis plus de
deux ans pour cette seconde édition
l'accent a été mis sur l'apprentissage
de l'outil web donc seniors où en êtes
vous au niveau de la recherche d'emploi
mais seniors où en êtes-vous dans votre
vie une vie qui est de plus en plus
connectés orienté numérique
la première édition a été un succès
total les personnes en sortant de là
nous ont demandé du temps pour apprendre
à aller sur internet pour découvrir
leurs droits donc en fait on a élargi
cette édition en faisant aussi découvert
les droits à ameli.fr avec tous les
droits à la santé est aussi au droit aux
informations sur tout ce qui concerne
les problèmes sociaux une manifestation
organisée par le pôle emploi et le pôle
insertion du département en partenariat
avec la caf la mission sociale rsa la
cité des métiers mais aussi diverses
associations
alors le forum pour les seniors ça tombe
de plain pied dans notre dos nos
missions premières donc accompagné
personnes bénéficiaires du rsa donc de
plus de 50 ans et de 60 ans pour la
mission sociale rsa donc aujourd'hui
nous avons effectué un travail en amont
pour pouvoir préparer les personnes donc
à cet après midi on accorde d'action
pour les informer du mieux possible sur
sur les droits et les droits auxquels il
posera ils peuvent prétendre
notamment tout ce qui est droit retraite
droit ce pas la possibilité de trouver
note une activité professionnelle donc à
travers les différents partenaires tels
que pôle emploi les dispositifs donc de
la caf qui peuvent qui peuvent être
comment dire ça un outil intéressant
pour la reprise d'activité donc en
citant toute logique encore une fois que
nous aujourd'hui nous sommes présents
face à la vague digital une partie de la
population réunionnaise rencontrent des
difficultés d'ordre financier ou de mes
connaissances
l'outil web plusieurs associations
étaient présentes afin de familiariser
les seniors à la pratique de
l'informatique
on va vers le tout numérique et donc du
couvent à ces gens ils sont complètement
perdus et ne savent pas comment faire
les c'est notre rôle de les aider à
apprendre à l'informatique à être
autonome et aller sur les sites en ligne
vu que tout en ce moment va se démarquer
à y aller c'est bien tout est donc du
coup bah ils ont beaucoup de mal avec
tout ce qu'il est va sourire clavier
écran ne sont pas encore en elles
connaissent pas ils ont peur et donc du
coup bah voila c'est notre travail
consiste à aider et bella dans un après
midi qui est encore une fois enchanté
les participants très réceptifs et
curieux d'apprendre à utiliser
l'ordinateur pour effectuer leurs
démarches en ligne auprès des différents
organismes pour connaître un petit peu
mieux les trucks l'ordinateur avec pôle
emploi pour la capitale parce qu'en ce
moment c'est plus que tendance
maintenant il faut pas nous apprend
notre mieux et un peu difficile
attention pas messieurs tout
enseignement fille qui pense et c'est
peut-être mon agent cubain comme avant
pas pu faire c'est l'occasion
d'apprendre d'un type bien il est là où
un type et de ses filiales ainsi fait
plutôt hivernale ou même service web
faso les infos mais d'annecy fut aussi
parce que parce que nous les vieilles m
il faut les employer des multiples comme
pour la première édition les seniors ont
répondu présents à ce forum ce n'est un
roux en êtes-vous une manifestation qui
devrait être réitérée prochainement